-Things are so depressing
that I want to thank you,
because you come from Wisconsin,
which is known for
cheese and beer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
And a lot of other things.
-And a lot of other things.
-[ Laughs ] Yes.
-But you were kind enough
to actually bring beer.
And while we're
talking about this,
I would much rather
have a beer out.
So can we bring it out?
-Yes.
-Yeah. Okay, great.
There we go.
This is -- Do you want to tell?
Yeah, we don't have to pour it
in a glass, right?
-Right, no.
-Okay, great. That's perfect.
So, this is a famous beer?
-Yes, it is.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a lot better.
That is a lot better.
You have an interesting
situation right now.
You have a re-election campaign
coming up in the midterms.
No candidate has had more
outside money spent
in order to defeat you
than you have.
And you don't actually have
an opponent yet, correct?
-Well, the primary
hasn't happened yet.
-The primaries haven't happened.
-So they haven't nominated
an opponent.
-So, they -- basically,
their problem is not that
they like the other person
more than you.
They just want to stop you.
-I think you're right. Yeah.
-Yeah.
And this is outside money
from billionaires.
How do you even approach
going into an election
knowing that you have so much
stacked up against you
as far as outside interests?
-Yeah. Well, I guess you would
have to choose --
-This helps, right?
[ Laughter ]
-I guess you have to
choose to sort of wear it
as a badge of honor.
Now, these donors,
they have an agenda.
They have --
They're special interests.
And I don't think they like me.
And whether it's, you know,
Big Pharma that I'm fighting for
making sure that they don't jack
up the prices of drugs
that Wisconsinites
need to survive
or insurance companies
that are working with folks
to try to get rid of coverage
for people with pre-existing
conditions.
Or, you know, Wall Street
hedge funds
that enjoy their tax loopholes.
I don't think they like me much
because I'm fighting for
the people of Wisconsin
and against them.
-I want to ask you about this.
You had started politics
in your 20s.
You were openly gay
for your first election.
And now you are the first
openly gay senator elected.
-Yes.
-To the United States.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-First woman too,
from Wisconsin.
-Yep. First woman
from Wisconsin. A lot of firsts.
And yet you said that was not as
much of a hurdle for voters
in your state
as you thought it would be.
Is that true?
-I think it is true.
I think that voters
are looking for somebody
who is in their corner,
who is listening.
Listening is a key trait these
days that we don't see enough.
And I think they are just
looking for somebody
who has their back and is
fighting for them every day.
Wisconsin's number one
in cheese production.
Almost a quarter of all
the cheese in the country.
We're America's dairy land.
We also have a huge
manufacturing sector.
So you know us for
beer and brats and cheese,
but you also know us for
motorcycles and bicycles
and you know us for ships.
We make ships for the Navy.
You know us
for all sorts of things.
And fighting for those things
that identify us
as Wisconsinites
and our work ethic
and those cultural traditions,
I think that's what's really
important to voters in my state.
-Well, that's fantastic.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's just a real pleasure
to meet you.
Yeah, cheers.
-But we can shake too.
-Yeah, we'll shake too. Senator
Tammy Baldwin, everybody.